au fond au fil de nos échanges qui sont
tout à fait passionnant il ya une
question qui se dégage comment redonner
à la france et aux français le droit de
choisir qui nous souhaitons accueillir
sur notre territoire
c'est ça la question clé ça suppose
brice hortefeux l'a dit de refonder
totalement le cadre européen des choix
d'immigration ça suppose un vrai
dialogue avec les pays d'origine et ça
suppose aussi de retrouver des leviers
nationaux et à cet égard nous avons une
proposition très forte qui consisterait
à donner au parlement
c'est à dire aux élus de la nation
chaque année le pouvoir de voter des
plafonds d'immigration des plafonds pas
des quotas pas des quotas qu'il faut
atteindre des plafonds qu'il ne faut pas
dépasser et donc on aurait chaque année
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
un débat et une décision définissant le
nombre maximal d'immigrés économique
d'immigrés aussi au titre du
regroupement familial que la france
accepteraient d'accueillir l'année
suivante des plafonds ça n'est pas
uniquement une question juridique
c'est une question juridique parce que
ça permettrait de contourner un certain
nombre d'obstacles constitutionnel
notamment qui sont extrêmement forts et
qui empêche jusqu'à lors de réguler et
de diminuer le regroupement familial et
c'est aussi cette histoire de plafond le
moyen d'un vrai débat démocratique d'un
vrai choix collectifs en définissant des
plafonds annuels
on retrouverait la maîtrise de nos choix
on leur donnerait aux français le droit
de choisir qui ils souhaitent accueillir
et donc qu'ils souhaitent refusé sur
notre territoire
ça devrait ensuite être décliner de
manière opérationnelle très concrète par
les préfets lorsqu'ils délivrent des
cartes de séjour
par les consuls lorsqu'il délivre des
visas c'est une orientation en tout cas
pour laquelle nous nous plaidons la
définition annuel de contingents
limitatif adapté aux capacités d'accueil
adaptées aussi aux besoins de notre
économie
il est bien évident que lorsque
l'économie est au point mort
lorsque le taux de chômage explose on ne
peut pas accueillir le même nombre de
ressortissants étrangers que dans les
années de forte croissance pour adapter
notre système d'immigration à la réalité
reprenons le contrôle en donnant au
parlement ce pouvoir nouveau de
définition de plafond limitatif
d'immigration merci qui